um good morning everybody counselors
good morning officers good morning to
Beth Evans who disappeared umit bit of
house keeping um if you have a mobile
phone can you either put it on silent or
turn it off please um if the fire alarms
go it means we have a situation and we
need to evacuate fairly quickly so
follow the officers out the building
please thank
you right moving on to the agenda item
one apologies for absence none received
chair none
re item number two minutes of the
standard committee held on the 28 of
June Pages 3 to
5A those who are present have read those
happy to move have a second after of the
minutes please and those who are present
can we vote on that please all those in
favor thank you extensions
please thank you
go item three Declarations of Interest
members with interest do declare to
declare should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of the interest
when the item is being
considered
item number four agreement of agenda
between Parts one and
two we have a proposal
please Ming to part two when necessary
thank you and those in favor please
second sorry do we have a second I think
did yeah yeah those in favor thank you
very
much urgent matters brought forward um I
don't have any urgent matters I'd just
like to inquire if you like we have a
vacancy for a par Parish representative
and I wonder whether we have have have
anybody in mind for that so I think we
try and make some effort to see if we
can put that vacancy on this committee
we can put that out good we yeah contact
Paris Clarks as well because we had the
May election so there might be some new
people on the committee so and I think
we to establish also the other
independent member Martin W hasn't been
to any of the Committees during since
last elections he is still an
independent person he has still been
helping with the standards investigation
oh thank you I think it's is work
commitments that have vent attending
committee right thank you very much um
we're not moving into part six item J at
the moment are we you want to proceed
with the
training sorry plan so we move on to
item seven forward
plan
well there's a matter that um I think
would be helpful for standards committee
to review which is the report from East
Evan District Council so I don't know if
chair would agree to that being on the
next standards agenda
it's quite a substantial report but I
think it's something that standards
should should
review yes um I would certainly commend
that um I've read part of that report
it's rather concerning and alarming and
I think it' be useful to this
committee look at that okay if we could
add that to the action plan forward plan
please um I wonder with regards to
sanctions
whether
um we the committee agree that we ought
to perhaps right the um the standards to
see whether we could urge them to review
this H I'm sure it's not going to be
done during this current parliamentary
session I'm sure they got other things
on their mind but it's something I'm
Keen to do just ask him to review what
availability we have regarding sanctions
when we have um issues that we need to
impose chair
S I think the LJ have been looking at
that because if we go back and I can't
remember the name of the minister at the
time he removed the um facility to
remove problem counsels at the time on
the basis of only done by the people at
election but up to that time there was
more sanctions in place Engish
name but that's not nice um but yeah I
think it could be looked at again is
what poers we used to have it's been the
move that would be high you again yes
they have no teeth and they don't appear
seem to have any teeth either and I've
also WR to the
LGA I'm encouraging them to make
representations to Parliament to see
whether something could be done about
that maybe we'll hear from Beth Evans
later on about what progress is being
made I know there is an inquiry going on
at the moment so we'll see some changes
than thank you very
much
good
[Music]
agenda sorry forward plan we done with
yes any anything else on the forward
plan review
discussed no thank you very much
and moving on to item eight exclusion of
the public chair Mo after me to move
that members of the public press are now
excluded for the rest of this meeting um
if I could have a proposal for that
please thank you those in favor we'll
now move into Part B thank you very much
Annie will you V in for to move into
part two I'm not not I'm just I have a
point information um why are we moving
to part two isn't there supposed to be a
reason Ming part two yeah it's to enable
a f FR discussion so that members can
put for questions to their in a in the
privacy or right I know what what that
is stated so there's going to be
something that needs to move in what
you're saying not automatic it is likely
Council Benson that something will arise
in part so yes during this C